[Music]
what might arguably be the most epic
show ever made Game of Thrones has
officially ended it woke together eight
seasons of shocking deaths and twists
and turns
here are 81 things you might have missed
in the final season of the show and of
course warning spoilers are coming the
show is no stranger to changing up the
imagery in the title sequences in season
8 episode 1 what's probably most
important to note is that the northern
wall has a giant hole reminding us of
the season 7 finale where the reanimated
Viserion obliterates the wall we also
get three new panels showing the fall of
the wall the red wedding and Daenerys
dragons being born in episode 2 the
north is in full battle preparation mode
and the slight changes in the opening
credits reflect that showing new
trenches lining the borders of
Winterfell also in the previous episode
the opening showed blue tiles
representing the army of the Dead
encroaching on last hearth by episode 2
the tiles fully encompass last hearth
the credits change again during the
opening of episode 3 the army of the
Dead is just outside Winterfell also the
torches and the crypts begin to go out
as the shot pans in earlier episodes the
torches stay on in episode 4 we now see
a new post war Winterfell the insides of
the castles are in shambles as bodies
burn outside the castle walls
in Episode five yet another change we
see scorpions those giant crossbow like
weapons that Qyburn created to slay
dragons sitting atop the walls at King's
Landing for the show's very last credit
sequence they changed yet again this
time there was no lion above the Iron
Throne showing that the Lannisters reign
has ended and while the red keep is
still shown as standing other parts of
King's Landing have been destroyed we
see a crack in the floor and the credits
that we see later in the episode as
Tyrion walks through the rubble back to
season 8 episode 1 as the season begins
we season heiress and Jon Snow entering
Winterfell with a large army and two
dragons this procession mirror season 1
episode 1 when Robert Baratheon arrived
at Winterfell to make Ned Stark hand the
king
not only do these two scenes look
similar but both scenes also share the
exact same music
[Music]
the boy pushing the crowd and climbing
is similar to both bran and Arya
speaking of Arya just like in season 1
episode 1 she catches a glimpse of the
Hound but they've got a lot more history
now the boy in this scene at the meeting
of the northern Lords is Lord Ned umber
who we saw last season pledging fealty
to how stark knows who is Ned he's the
son of small john number who died at the
Battle of the bastards at the end of the
episode you may not have known where
tormund barrack and the others are
treading carefully well they're actually
at last hearth which is south of the
wall but north of Winterfell and it's
where the umbers live
at last hearth Bera kills the reanimated
net number with his flaming sword
illuminating a spiral pattern we've seen
this pattern before back in season 3 we
saw the body parts of dismembered nights
Watchmen and horses
we saw the pattern again in season 5
when the children of the forest created
the night king and then again in season
7 in the cave drawings at Dragonstone in
another not to season one John and arias
reunion in this episode is a close a
mirror of when John and Arya said
goodbye in season 1 episode 2 they hug
in a near identical way and that's when
John gave Aria needle her beloved sword
in this episode John notices that Arya
still has the blade we see John fly a
dragon for the first time which is
certainly momentous but there's actually
more going on here the dragon John flies
is ragle named after his real father
Rhaegar Targaryen in the season 8
trailer we saw this same scene but John
was not in the shop this scene is no
doubt a reference to when John made love
to his first love Ygritte in a cave near
a waterfall according to the creators
this location in season 8 is also where
John would have hunted when he was
younger in this episode ginjury and Arya
reunite Gendry calls Arya lady Stark
- which Arya replies don't call me that
Gendry then replies as you wish milady
this is a direct mirror of a
conversation they had in season 2
episode 2 I should be calling you milady
do not call me milady Ozma lady commands
in the scene with Bronn Qyburn gives
Bronn a crossbow the weapons Cersei
wants Bronn to use to kill her trader
brothers this is significant because you
may remember that Tyrion uses a crossbow
that looks just like this one to kill
their father Tywin Lannister we see
Bronn and this crossbow again in episode
4
[Music]
the episode opens on Jamie who's found
himself on trial by Daenerys and the
Starks he must answer for his murder of
Danny's father King Aerys ii as well as
his role in Ned Stark's untimely death
when Daenerys demands that Jaime explain
why he deserted Cersei he responds
because this goes beyond loyalty this is
about survival
his words echo Brienne's in the season 7
finale loyalty witness decided that
Jaime can join their ranks grey worm
begrudgingly returns his sword known as
widows wail what she commits widows wail
widows wail is one of two blades the
Lannisters forged after melting down ice
the ancestral sword of how stark its
sister sword is Oathkeeper which Jaime
bestowed upon Brienne Jaime served under
Brienne's command in the Battle of
Winterfell the two blades of ice have
been reunited in Winterfell for the
first time since Ned left Winterfell in
season one at the exact moment that
Jamie has rearmed we hear a familiar
musical cue
the song is Jamie's theme first played
when Jamie recounts to Brienne the real
reason he killed Aerys Targaryen capture
rosette and again as he headed to
Riverrun to break the black vicious
siege the flirtation between Aria and
ginjury visually mirrors one of their
past interactions and season two
during the Lannister brother reunion
Tyrion repeats his tried-and-true joke
from all the way back in season 1 how
would you like to die Tyrion son of
Tywin in my own bed at the age of 80
with a belly full of wine and a girl's
mouth around mic after meeting to
discuss tactics Jon stands with his
former brothers Samwell and Ed the
latter of whom announces and now our
watch begins he's returned to the oath
of the Brotherhood no gathers begins
after Jon announced his watch has ended
back in season 6 she's ended now the
brothers must again take on the burden
of defending the realm next there's a
doomsday romance scene between Aria and
ginjury he confides in her that he's
Roberts bastard and the last of the
Baratheon's it's a direct reversal of a
scene in season 3 when are you revealed
to him her true identity as a stark it's
aria of house [ __ ] their physical union
echoes Robert and Ned's proposed unions
of their houses underneath the crypts at
Winterfell in season 1 when they undress
Aria reveals some grisly scars the
results of stab wounds inflicted on her
by the wave in season 6 meanwhile in
front of Winterfell fireplace Jaime
holds a spontaneous knighting ceremony
for Brienne on the eve of her biggest
battle yet she's proclaimed the knight
of the Seven Kingdoms which is the title
of episode 2 it's also the name of a
trio of novellas written by george RR
martin as a spinoff from the Song of Ice
and Fire series the books follow a
chivalrous Knight known as Sir Duncan
the tall who's actually mentioned
several times in the show I could tell
you about ser Duncan the tall at a 2016
fan convention Martin confirmed that
Brienne was descended from Sir Duncan we
can guess that's where she gets her
unusual height and her bravery
after brian's induction into the
knighthood Podrick performs Ginny of old
stones his own impressive rendition of a
song from the original Song of Ice and
Fire books the song references Ginny
voltones a character from the books who
was married to Prince Duncan Targaryen
this version of the song included new
lyrics and the episodes closing credits
even debuted a cover of the song
performed by Florence and the Machine
[Music]
Patrick singing is paired with a montage
showing the people of Winterfell making
their final preparations the music and
visuals evoked this scene from Return of
the King set to the sad tune of Pippin
song The Edge of Night
[Music]
the similar mood makes sense especially
given that the director of the impending
battle scene cited Lord of the Rings as
an inspiration when Arya hands Sansa a
weapon for the crypts Sansa says she
doesn't know how to use it - which Arya
responds stick them with the pointy end
her tongue and cheek advice were caused
John's words when he gave her needle in
the second ever episode of the show
first listen sticking with the pointy
end I know which end to use it's a fan
favorite piece of dialogue that inspired
the name of season 1 episode 8 the
pointy end to light up the blades of the
Dothraki Melisandre recites the phrase
axial ownio which in valerian means
lords light it's the same spell that
beric uses to ignite his own sword
however unlike Melisandre Barrick can
merely think the words and a flame will
appear in the midst of the flames the
hound is momentarily immobilized with
fear he is after all para phobic a
consequence of the burn trauma inflicted
on him by his brother Greg Oracle game I
heard what your brother did you press
your face to the fire like you're a nice
juicy mutton chop
when Lyanna Mormont dies she takes one
of the White Walkers biggest assets with
her stabbing the white giant in the eye
he collapses in the same place at
Winterfell where one one fell from an
arrow in the eye after the Battle of the
bastards
[Music]
when beric Dondarrion sacrifices himself
to save Arya he holds his body in the
doorway in the figure of a cross
it's a christ-like pose and a fitting
death for a figure who's been
resurrected time and time again why you
you think I don't ask myself that every
hour of every day why am I here
what am I supposed to do in his last
moments that about barek finally found
his true purpose the reason Lord of
Light allowed him to be brought back
from death so many times it was
ultimately to save Arya so that she
could go on to kill the night King
but before that Arya finds herself
reuniting with Melisandre back in season
3 the red woman predicted that they'd
meet again and that Arya would shut mini
eyes forever brown eyes
blue eyes very nice
eyes you'll shut forever blue eyes of
course refers to those at the neck came
a turning point comes in the battle when
Melisandre reminds Arya of the motto
recited by her sword instructor Syrio
Forel that is only one God and His name
is death and there is only one thing we
say to death not today the combination
of the battle at the godswood was
foreshadowed in one of Theon Greyjoy's
first ever scenes in the series the
moment comes right after Catelyn Stark
says that she thinks the Lannisters
purposely pushed brand out of the window
if it's war they want it comes to that
you know I'll stand behind you is there
going to be a battle in the godswood
Arya ultimately kills the night king
with cat's paw the dagger that bran had
given her at the same spot under the
godswood back in season 7 it's likely he
knew that she needed to slay the night
king I don't want it he shall
it's for their in steel the blade has
lived a long life and it was used by the
Lannisters hit man in an attempt to kill
brand back in season one Arya plunges
the dagger right into the night Kings
chest exactly where the children of the
forest stabbed him with dragonglass
which we saw in brands vision back in
season four he was created by dragon
glass and uncreated by Valyrian steel
as the survivors celebrate and drink
Tyrion Podrick Brienne and Jaime play a
drinking game it's the same one we've
seen Tyrion play several times
throughout the show first in season one
with Shaitan Bronn and another time he
tries and fails to play it with grey
worm in Masson day anyone not drinking
is disrespecting our queen if you look
closely you can see series creators DB
Weiss and David Benioff in the banquet
hall you can spot them as tormund gives
his big speech about Jon meanwhile Arya
doesn't join the others in the banquet
hall contree finds her and proposes
asking her to be the lady of storms end
not long after Daenerys declared him
Lord of storms end she says no and tells
him I don't want to be a lady and I'm
not a lady I never happened
That's not me this is a callback to
multiple moments in the show the first
from season 1 episode 4 when Ned talks
to her about her future as lady and she
says That's not me
there's another callback to this in
season 7 episode 2 Stormborn
when arya tries to get Nymeria to come
back to Winterfell with her when Nymeria
walks away arya realizes her direwolf
was meant to roam free and she says bran
tells Tyrion that his wheelchair is the
same one that Darren Targaryen built for
his nephew 120 years ago Darren was the
oldest son of King Aegon the 3rd in the
books Jon Snow mentions Daren as a sort
of historical hero of his bronto's
Tyrion I've been shoveling Lannister and
what do I have to show Tyrion starts to
respond power resides where men believe
before being cut off this is a callback
to season 2 episode 3 what his dead may
never die Varys says these exact words
to Tyrion power resides where men
believe it resides it's a trick a shadow
on the wall Daenerys the sweet is taken
by surprise when you're on in the golden
company shot down Rey though there were
hints throughout the episode that the
Dragons were weak if you look closely
you can see that reyga's wings are full
of holes
both were Syrian and regal were brought
down in similar ways one by spear and
one by era
[Music]
Euron uses a scorpion weapon to take
down ragel we've seen scorpions before
season 8 they were invented by Qyburn
and were last seen in the season 7
episode the spoils of war during the
loot train attack bran uses one against
rogue on he hits but fails to kill him
Cersei gives the order from asan day's
execution but the mountain swings the
sword in the pilot episode Ned Stark
says the man who passes the sentence
should swing the sword
this is not something Lannisters do
Joffrey gives the order to someone else
for Ned's head and speaking of Ned Stark
in the first season Cersei tells Ned
when you play the game of Thrones you
win or you die
this explains why Cersei refuses to
surrender for her she either takes the
throne or loses her life during the
episode both Daenerys and Cersei are
seen in their full house garb Daenerys
is wearing full Targaryen read at the
celebratory feast a nod to her leaning
into her house words of fire and blood
she's only ever worn red with another
color in the final scene with this
episode she's wearing red and white
Cersei is also in full red for the
episode just as Daenerys is embracing
her Targaryen nature Cersei is back to
full lannister strength lion necklace
and all
[Music]
[Music]
the fifth episode opens with Varys
writing a letter about John's true
parents it's a mirror of the letter Ned
Stark wrote to Stannis Baratheon back in
season one exposing that Jaime Lannister
is a true father of Cersei's children
not rapper Baratheon you will sail to
Dragonstone tonight you will place this
in the hand of Stannis Baratheon Lord
Baelish like Tyrion tavares in the last
episode tries to convince Ned to drop it
and allow Joffrey to take the throne if
you would be wise to deny it to him and
to make sure Joffrey succeeds in Mike
Ned Varys pays the price for his actions
with his life as Varys writes his
letters he's interrupted by Marta a
little girl acting as one of his spies
we've actually seen Marta before she was
hiding in the crypt
along with Varys during the Battle of
Winterfell in Episode three back in
season seven episode two Danny tells
Varys if you haven't betrayed me I'll
burn you alive
well it's clear Danny made good on that
promise when Tyrion sets Jaime free to
go rescue Cersei Jaime says
Cersei once called me the stupidest
Lannister that's a callback to season
seven episode 7 sedition knows I was she
finished next Cersei was berating Jaime
for heading north to fight against the
threat beyond the wall this conversation
was the last time Jaime and Cersei saw
each other and takes place in the exact
same spot where they were reunited as
the red keep crumbled in this episode we
get this scene of Danny's armies
charging against the remaining golden
company forces after a large chunk of
them are blown away by dragon's fire the
shot is a mirror image of the battle the
bastards
when Jon is faced with an onslaught of
men and horses but unlike John's heroic
fighting stance
Harry Stricklin the leader of the golden
company runs for his life as Danny burns
the outer wall at King's Landing we see
Cersei standing in the exact same spot
she stood when she burned down the Sept
of Baelor back in season six only this
time she's on the losing side that
Danny's dragon drogon would fly over
King's Landing was foreshadowed in brans
vision in season 4 episode 2 as he
touches the weirwood tree brand saw the
shadow of a dragon above through
tops as the Hound attempts to convince
Aria to leave the red keep instead of
going to kill Searcy he grabs her and
shouts look at me the hound does the
same thing during the Battle of
Blackwater in season two with Sansa
after she refuses to flee King's Landing
with him
this shows the hounds arc with the stark
daughters look at me the game Bowl
finally happened which certainly comes
as no surprise but what is significant
about the showdown is that the Hound
dies with the zombified Mountain by
falling into the fiery city below as we
mentioned the Hound is deathly afraid of
fire because his brother put his face
into a fire when they were children but
as the show's producer describes it the
one thing stronger in the Hound and his
fear of fire is the hatred for the
person who put that fear there in the
first place in season 3 episode 9 as
Arya and the Hound travel arya tells him
someday I'm gonna put a soul to your eye
and out the back of your skull that's
exactly what the Hound ends up doing to
his brother the mountain we hear a
familiar composition at two different
points during the episode the rains of
castamere plays once as Cersei realizes
she must flee the red keep
[Music]
and when jaime and cersei faced certain
death it's a mix of that song with the
light of the seven
it's a clue that these characters won't
survive the episode season 3 episode 9
has called the rains of castamere and we
hear the song during the famous red
wedding the light of the seven
composition though refers back to
Circe's victory in season six this
episode saw the deaths of twins and
lovers Cersei and Jaime Lannister
experiencing one final embrace before
the red keep collapses upon them this
moment was foreshadowed back in season
five when bran asks Jaime how we would
want to die and Jaime replies you know
shapsug women anyway and it appears he
does just that
there are other moments from the book
that foreshadow this moment in the books
Jaime says I cannot die while Cersei
lives we will die together as we were
born together and the show adapted this
line from the book back in season 1
Jaime and I are more than brother and
sister we shared a woman came into this
world together we belong together we see
a white horse standing in the middle of
the ruins of King's Landing Arya rides
the horse out of the city white horses
the mythology often symbolize triumph
but in Christianity they can also Herald
death like in the book of Revelation or
is this a reference to shadow facts in
Lord of the Rings
[Music]
it's the Lord of all shoes it's also
worth noting that the young girl aria is
unable to save is holding on to a little
white horse
[Music]
Daenerys stands in the ruins of King's
Landing overlooking her massive army the
image almost directly mirrors this shot
from Lord of the Rings the two towers as
Saruman overlooks his army before
commanding them to march to helms deep
like Daenerys Saruman also descended
into madness in that speech she
specifically speaks to the Dothraki
saying you kept all your promises to me
you killed my enemies and their iron
suits you tore down their stone houses
you gave me the Seven Kingdoms she's
referring to the original promise Khal
Drogo gave danny's unborn son in season
one
Danny recalls this speech in season six
when she names all the Dothraki her
blood riders in Tyrion cell John repeats
the words of Aemon Targaryen the maester
of the Nights Watch Amon offered this
piece of wisdom when John was
considering deserting the Nights Watch
in order to come to Rob's aid sooner or
later in every man's life there comes a
day when it is not easy a day when he
must choose in retrospect his words
sound pretty prophetic Danny's
premonition in the season 2 finale Valar
morghulis
finally came to fruition in it she walks
through a ruin - throne room that's
blanketed in snow in episode 6 however
she actually touched the throne in the
vision she did not the Lord of the Rings
comparisons were plenty moments after
John murders Daenerys drogon flies in
and in mourning burns the Iron Throne to
a crisp this is yet another instance
mirroring Lord of the Rings as pointed
out by Johanna Robinson of Vanity Fair
the Iron Throne is similar to the One
Ring an object of absolute power that is
absolutely corrupting in this instance
Daenerys was like Gollum looking
wide-eyed when she finally obtains what
she's been searching for all her life
and then like the One Ring the throne is
destroyed by fire melting in front of
our eyes taking Daenerys along with it
as the Starks stand at the King's
Landing docks and prepare to go their
separate ways
grey worm also departs he's heading
towards naath
which is where Masson day is from right
before the Battle of Winterfell and a
few episodes before Masson day's tragic
death grey worm tells Masson day that
after the war ends that he would like to
leave Westeros and asks her where she
would want to go she responds as she
would like to go see Nath again I'd like
to see the beaches again where I'm kept
his promise but had to make the journey
alone the Starks go their separate ways
John to the north Sansa back to
Winterfell and Arya somewhere out west
to lands unknown to Westeros see this
was yet another Lord of the Rings
parallel
the King ends with Frodo Gandalf and
other characters sailing away to the
undying lands the two big farewells are
visual and emotional mirrors of one
another and speaking of which Ari has
had the urge to explore what's west of
Westeros since at least season six when
she had this conversation with the
Braavosi actress lady crane well will
you go s was his east the Westeros is
West but was west of Westeros I don't
know
nobody does so a lobster the edge of the
world maybe I'd like to see that the
Great Council meets in the dragon pit to
decide tarry ins fate and who will rule
Westeros among the people on the council
Samwell Tarly at mere Tully Robin Arryn
yon Royce
so Brienne of Tarth ser Davos Seaworth
Gentry Baratheon Yara Greyjoy an unnamed
prince of Dorne and then Sansa Arya and
bran there are also a few unidentified
Lords when possibly from the
westerland's and another might be from a
lesser-known house in the reach Edmure
Tully Catelyn Stark's younger brother
has provided some of the most memorable
moments of comic relief on the show and
this episode was no different
most memorably in season 3 he tried to
light his father's funeral pyre and
couldn't hit it
breanne is the new Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard and she has a raven sigil on
her armor representing brand the new
king we see Brienne riding in the white
book a book with records of the deeds of
all the members of the Kingsguard
Brienne read Jaime's page back in season
four episode four thereafter known as
the Kingslayer it's the duty of the Lord
commands to fill those pages and there's
still room left in mine
now that Brianna's Lord Commander she
fills Jaime's pages with the rest of his
life and his death we get to see exactly
what Brienne writes in these pages about
Jaime we see her refer to the loot train
battle from season seven episode four as
the Battle of gold road which is a new
name for that battle and a better one at
the small council meeting Sam presents
Tyrion with a Song of Ice and Fire
it's a history of wars after King Robert
written by archmaester ebro's sam says
he helped with the title this is a
callback to season seven I'm not writing
a chronicle of the wars following the
death of King Robert the first so he can
sit on the shelf
unread but you don't like the title what
would you call it that possibly
something a bit more poetic when the new
small council of symbols bran says or
soon there won't be no more coin so
Davos who's master of ships corrects him
by saying anymore
this is particularly funny because when
we first met Davos he couldn't read he
was taught by Shireen Stannis
Baratheon's daughter the first [ __ ]
tonight in Tyrians final moment on the
show he says he brought a jackass and a
honeycomb into a brothel but here's the
thing we've all heard this joke before
Tyrion first attempted to tell it in his
confession to Lysa Arryn in season 1
before she cuts him off I was a jackass
and a honeycomb into a brothel he then
starts telling the same joke to grey
worm inves on day in season 6 episode 3
Oathbreaker before he's interrupted once
again I've once walked into a brothel
with a honeycomb and a jackass
madam says well it looks like we'll
never hear the punchline now Tyrion's
fussy chair rearranging is a habit
leftover from Thailand small council
meetings which were memorable for
passive-aggressive moves like this
[Music]
Santa's coronation dress represents the
independence of the north it has a
pattern of a weirwood tree which grows
in the forests up north the symbolism
reminds us just how much she's evolved
since longing for the south in season 1
santa's crown also resembles one of
Circe's crowns especially from the back
it suggests that Sansa took on the best
of Circe's queenly qualities a lot of
fans voiced their disappointment after
Jon parted ways with ghost in episode 4
without so much as petting his wolf
goodbye that episode's director David
Nutter explained that cgi considerations
were the real reason behind Jon's abrupt
send-off luckily the visual effects team
was able to pull together this last shot
of Jon and ghosts reunion the final shot
of the show is Jon Snow
walking off beyond the wall with the
wildlings through the woods the show
ends in the exact same place as it began
the pilot episode begins with a group of
men from the Nights Watch going beyond
the wall where they encounter dead
wildlings and then a white Walker now
they are free to walk beyond the wall
with no whites or white walkers in sight
in a mistake seen across the world a
coffee cup accidentally ended up in
season 8 episode 4 the last of the
Starks and unfortunately it happened
again in the finale during the council
meeting you can spot not one but two
water bottles that were left behind when
by Sam and one by dulles
do we miss anything let us know in the
comments
[Music]